[Music]
in just three years
Visual Studio code has gone from being
non-existent to the single most popular
code editor among all developers
according to the Stack Overflow 2018
survey I personally like it because it's
minimal yet super powerful and free and
open source in this episode I'll show
you exactly what I mean by taking you
through my top 10 pro tips or using the
BS code effectively if you're new here
hit subscribe and you'll find a full
write-up on angular firebase comm the
first thing you should know is how to
get around the file system quickly you
can open up vs code by running code from
the command line with the directory that
you want to open it the quickest way to
move around is to memorize a few hotkeys
or key bindings if you hit ctrl K it'll
bring up a full list of key bindings
that you can search through and
customize as needed but the single most
important one is ctrl P which brings up
the command palette we'll be using the
command palette a lot in this video so
don't forget this one to navigate
between files you can simply start
typing the file name and it will
automatically search through your tree
to find the corresponding file that's
way quicker than trying to navigate
through a directory tree by clicking but
sometimes you might want to bookmark
specific lines of code and navigate to
them later for that I recommend using a
bookmark plugin which will allow us to
highlight a block of code set a bookmark
number for it and then easily navigate
to it later on using that command
palette and BS code as you probably
noticed I'm here in an angular project
so I'm going to install some snippets to
generate a lot of the boilerplate code
for me and angular we have two really
good snippet libraries one from Mike
Moreland and one from John Papa and you
can use them both together when you
install snippets they're automatically
added to the vs code intellisense so say
I need to code up something really
tedious like an NG switch statement I
can simply start typing the prefix in
the snippet library and it will
automatically generate this code for me
there's even snippets available for
libraries like angular material ng XS
and many others number E is vs codes
integrated command line terminal you can
pull it up by simply dragging from the
bottom of the screen or you can use the
control back tick key binding you can
also pull up the command palette with
control P and open it there what's
really cool is that vs code will
automatically recognize scripts that you
have set up in your prod
in JavaScript you probably have
something set up with NPM or maybe with
grunt or gulp you can simply type in NPM
and it will show all of your scripts
right there automatically so you can run
them without ever having to type
anything with that we can segue into the
next major feature which is intellisense
intellisense is just a fancy word for
code auto-completion and if you use a
language that strong typed like
typescript you'll get incredible
developer tooling and BS code you'll see
this automatically as you're coding but
you can pull it up manually with control
space as well code completion is pretty
self-explanatory but there's some pretty
cool things you can do with it let's say
we're going into a large typescript file
for the first time and we want to see
all the methods and classes that are
defined in this file we can go into the
command palette type in the @ symbol and
that will give us all the interfaces
methods and properties defined in this
file in a strong type language another
thing you might want to do is pick the
type definitions for a given interface
it can be really disrupted to have
multiple files open at once looking for
different type definitions but you can
simply click on an interface and say
peak definition and we'll find that in
your project even if it's buried in your
node modules and show you the properties
on that interface on the flip side of
this you might be looking at an
interface and want to know how many
references you have to it in a project
if you right click and go to find
references it will show you exactly
which files are referencing this
interface in your project but let's say
I'm working with an interface and I
decide I don't like the name of it I can
highlight it then right click and say
rename symbol or just hit f2 and give it
a new name that not only updates the
current file but also every other file
in the project with that reference and
that's a lot safer than using just a
regular Find and Replace because it's
looking at the actual code reference and
not the text itself yet another good
reason to strong type your code now
while we're on the topic of types I want
to show you this really cool extension
called paste JSON as code almost all
apps make calls to api's that return
JSON but you might not have an easy way
to actually strong type this response in
your project I'm in the Twitter API
right now and I'm just going to copy and
paste this example response in JSON
format I'll go ahead and paste the JSON
into a tweet JSON file and then create a
new file called tweet TS then I can open
up the command palette and just enter
that paste is JSON command and we'll set
the top-level interface name as tweet
and then magically we get this whole set
of interfaces that model this API
response so that means you can get
incredible developer tooling for any API
that you work with whether it has types
or not okay I think I've heard just
about enough of types let's just chill
out for a second
hit ctrl K Z to go into Zen mode this
will give us a viewport with all of the
distractions removed if you don't care
what your docker container is doing or
what the git status is you can just go
into Zen mode and focus on writing code
while we're at it let's install the
Spotify extension for vs code and throw
on some carbon-based life forms and just
chill out but unfortunately we relax a
little too hard and now our application
is broken let's go into the debugger
panel and see how that might be able to
help us out
you get to the debugger by clicking on
the bug icon and I have a simple node
script setup here node works out of the
box but you can also install extensions
to support different runtimes in the
script I have two separate functions
that are each updating a global variable
and we'll just run these one after the
other I can set up breakpoints in my
code by simply adding a red dot in
between the line numbers this will stop
the execution of the script once it hits
this breakpoint and then you can inspect
the local state and the call stack and
things like that all I have to do is
click the play button and it will
automatically attach the debugger to
this process you can see here it shows
all of the local variables as well as
all of our global variables and node you
can also go down to the debugger console
and start executing commands within the
context of the script and we'll have
access to its current state so if we
want to inspect the name of a variable
we just type it down here in the command
line and it will print that out in the
console debugging node is great but
generally my front-end apps are a lot
more complex than my back-end apps
I'd like to debug my angular
applications in the context of the
Chrome browser after installing the
Chrome extension we can go back to the
debugger and click the play button but
this time use Chrome then we can set up
a launch configuration for this specific
app which in angular's case it'll be
served on localhost 4200 then we can go
into one of our component files and set
up some breakpoints where we want to
have the debugger run in the browser
I'll set up one break point before the
components actually initialized and then
another one that
we'll run on a button click then you can
see if we click play it will launch
Chrome and have our debugger running
here which we can control from vs code
when we click play again it will define
the title and we can actually highlight
over properties in the code and it will
tell us the state of the data managing
state in a web application is one of the
biggest challenges and this debugger can
really help you do that more effectively
another huge way that vs code helps you
out is with your git version control
dealing with git in a large project gets
pretty hard to do from the command line
you might have already noticed that vs
code automatically highlights all of
your files untracked or new files or
green modified files are yellow and
files with Wynton errors are red if we
want to commit some changes we can just
go into the git tab at our commit
message and we're done we don't have to
do any get add or get flag message from
the command line but what if we actually
didn't mean to commit that code well we
can come up here to the options menu and
just roll back that commit and you can
run pretty much every other git command
from this menu as well if we want to
revert some changes on a specific file
we can simply do that by clicking this
revert button and that will discard all
of the changes that we made or if we
just want to commit a couple files
individually we can click the plus
button and that will only stage those
files for your next commit so that's
super powerful on its own but I want to
know about the git status pretty much
everywhere in my code I want to know who
changed what and when it was chained
because I'm working with a team of
junior developers and they keep screwing
things up we can install get lens from
the extensions page and if we go back to
the git tab you'll see that we have an
additional panel here with all of that
get one's data it makes it a lot easier
to traverse the git tree and also deal
with things like stashes and tags and
also your remote repositories but it
doesn't just stop at the gate panel it
actually annotates all of your code with
information about git if we go into a
file and just hover over a piece of code
it will tell us exactly who wrote that
code when they wrote it and it's commit
ID this brings us to vs code live share
which is a brand new feature in the
editor it allows you to connect your
github or Azure account to vs code and
then collaborate with multiple team
members on a single document in real
it's kind of like the Google Docs of
writing code I've been able to use this
with some angular firebase pro members
to collaborate on issues and it's been
super useful you can install the
extension and you'll need to connect a
github account or a Microsoft account
after that it's just a matter of
clicking share and vs code will return a
link that you can pass along to other
team members I probably could have
covered about 90 other topics in this
video but I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if it helped you please
like and subscribe and if you're serious
about building apps consider becoming a
pro member at angular firebase com we
can write code together using vs code
live share and work on strategies to get
your app built and shipped as soon as
possible thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you soon
[Music]